[Music]
lindsay is in
raleigh hey lindsay welcome to the
ramsay show
hi i'm so excited to be talking to you
guys
you too what's up um so
uh my daughter is about to turn one so
this is kind of thinking
um far in the future but we all
you often talk about how more is caught
than taught and my husband and i grew up
putting
you know watching our parents put their
ties in the offering plate
and now my husband and i are paying our
ties like
once a month online so i was wondering
if you had
any ideas short of starting to write
checks again
um no i would not our daughter
um you know that we tied instead of just
talking about it
well what i did when uh
you know rachel and denise uh even
daniel but
more rachel and denise were uh 10 or 12
they graduated to sit at the kitchen
table when i
in quotes did the bills you know what
i'm talking about right
we used to sit down with a stack of
bills at the kitchen table with a
checkbook
and we had a check this thing called a
checkbook register and you would balance
the checkbook now this is a long time
ago
those young women are in their 30s now
okay so uh but no one does
that anymore i don't balance my
checkbook physically anymore it's done
online
obviously i reconcile my checkbook you
don't call it balance anymore probably
but um and i don't pay my electric bill
with a check anymore but i but i
remember distinctly denise my oldest
the first time she had an aha moment and
it sounds like it's not much money today
but it was a long time ago
i wrote a check for 238 dollars for the
electric bill and she saw the amount
and i used to let them write out the
checks and then i would sign them
so the electric company would get these
checks from a third grader
you know it's fabulous but they cash
right so and i would sign them and when
she wrote out 238 dollars her eyes got
big and she's like oh man
so i'm thinking to myself when you ask
this question what's the uh
modern day equivalent of letting your
kid pay the electric bill so they have a
dad no wonder you tell us to shut the
door cause it's 238 dollars what's the
modern day equivalent when she did that
because her eyes got big and she's like
suddenly understood
why i said you weren't raised in a barn
shut the dadgum door
you're letting your air conditioning in
the backyard like every one of us have
told
every kid since time began right
and so um but she's the little light
bulb no pun intended went on over her
head and she said okay this is expensive
same thing happens with giving when you
watched your parents put it in the tray
in the offering same thing happens with
rachel she makes each when she's doing a
talk on giving she talks about
remembering sitting on my knee or
sitting beside me in church we're all
dressed up back in the day used to
dressed up to go to church and you know
she watched me put the physical check in
like you're asking about
what's the modern day equivalent i guess
it's filling out the little thing online
with your
keyboard and hitting submit i can tell
you what we do in our house okay and
we we are intentional about cash because
i want them to see it
and so we actually do pull out a little
bit of money and sometimes you can at a
grocery store
um you can take 20 or 50 bucks over and
you know that way you don't have to go
to a bank
when you're just using your debit card
but we use the my kids both have
the ramsey banks here and it's become so
ingrained in our conversation they know
that the giving how do they observe you
giving
oh that's her question okay gotcha so we
teach them about saving and giving
um and they actually put it in the
collection plate but i we sit down and
hank's old enough now he's 11.
he rolls his eyes but he sits down and
watches us pay the bills and so he'll
watch
online he'll watch us click it he'll
show us look at the budget this is how
much we're giving
right so the amount and in relation to
especially now that he knows here's what
he gets paid for mowing the yard
and that's how much electric caught and
that's how much you are given to church
right that's how he starts to see that
but we sit down and he looks at the
computer screen with it's called
teaching them the value of a dollar
right it's an old saying that dads used
to say in the 50s
and those of us that are throwbacks
still say stuff like that so i think the
key here is not overthinking it
yeah but however you do it involve them
in that rhythm
yeah they need to ex because here's the
thing
hank's 11 and he has never ex
for him to experience a checkbook would
be more foreign than for him to
experience giving
so let him experience it the way he
experiences everything else in his life
which is freaking online
right you know so he's going to hit
submit and that's going to
that's going to penetrate his heart and
soul faster than
some weird analog version of something
we remember from our childhood
so let i mean the way he does
everything's online so why wouldn't he
do giving online but he also i want him
to participate in giving of his own oh
that's yeah that's that's
building their little muscle but she's
saying she saw more
caught than taught she saw it modeled
how do i model it that's right
and that's what i'm that's what i'm
leaning in on so that's a really really
good question i love it yeah
and and of course the other thing is
this we're not going to make any of this
legalistic it's all going to be
we're trying to create the spirit around
this which is what god was doing
when he's taught us to talk and that's
where the giving conversation
also i bring hank over and let him see
whenever we tip
in a restaurant i want him to see what
the bill was and then how much we're
tipping
and i i'm an obnoxious it's a big deal
to me those people get treated like
trash
and um so i want it it's giving us a
good tipper
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um i just want
to be clear yeah
yeah i'll help you with your hate mail
okay thank you no i tip too much but i
want him to see that and it's an ethos
of giving like you said it's a way of
it's a way of living it's a way of
feeling the rhythm of life it's we hold
this with an open hand
that's not mine it's not my stuff called
money is it's for enjoyment and
generosity and blessings
and and you know and we save some of it
why so we can have more enjoyment and
generosity and blessings is the only
point in raising your net worth right
it's not just because you want to
become a baby steps millionaire it's
wonderful but why but why what's
why what's the point yeah so you can tip
outrageously
wonderfully yeah obnoxiously yeah that's
a great one
i like that that's a good question i
love that question so i'd be interested
to see like rachel
i need i wish she was sitting here i
would ask her because i don't know
i mean i know they're teaching the kids
out of the financial piece how to do the
stuff
but i don't know how much they're
looking over like little amelia's
looking over winston or rachel's
shoulders when they're actually doing
their giving because i guarantee you
winston does that online
oh yeah i just wonder i just wonder in
five ten years we'll you walk through
your living room and say hey alexis in
the church
a thousand dollars i'm not gonna have a
lexus do anything i'm not me neither
brother
they're listening alexis listen to the
dave ramsey show
hey alexis listen to the ramsay show i
just turned on stuff everywhere in
america
just then it's actually a little thing
one of those little one of those little
scripts we put it in there it's awesome
if i just said hey alexis let's say john
delaney show it would say
sorry what show is that let's say
you and five no that's right 50 million
others i mean i've never seen anything
like your show take off
all kidding aside you always act like
there's four people listening when we
know there's millions our numbers say
how
popular this show is but that's a great
that's a great segue a great question
because
here's the thing um
is there a certain technology that is
right or wrong
when it comes to handling your money no
there is not
what you've got to be careful with in
your own life and what you're modeling
before your kids
is what is it doing to your psyche
you know because anytime that the
technology makes it easier for you to
spend money and your brain does not
register the pain
that you your pain centers are not
activated that you just did spending
that's called low friction in marketing
and we make it really where you don't
feel the pain to buy something
you will buy more of it click click
click click click click click click
uh prime deliver tomorrow we'll deliver
it this afternoon on your porch that's
right we wouldn't want you to be
inconvenienced by waiting even overnight
before the sun goes down
we will bring you stuff and oh by the
way did you notice that card that was
already registered in your little prime
account just got ding-dinged
oh i think i'll take two i'll have three
see that's a problem
that's a problem